fungi
bitcoin and decentralization
such a critical topic
for the future of humanity
biomimicry
realize that everything connects to
everything else
leonardo da vinci
mycelium is the neurological network of
nature
pulse statements
this is what we are biomimicking with
our architectures
re-architect society based on the
separation
of money and state
let's read that again re-architect
society
based on the separation of money
and state deflationary assets
bitcoin teaches us to delay consumption
today
in order to reap greater benefits
tomorrow
the mycelial archetype is embedded
in our species the mycelial archetype is
an emergent
property of biology which means the
world wide web
and bitcoin were inevitable
i have the links in the bio to two very
influential
articles that i read on this brandon
quittims article and dan held's
article and also a very awesome fungal
video and some
important bitcoin nomenclature
defy means decentralized finance
defy is the antidote to macro
uncertainty
defy is a catalyst for human evolution
meeting basic needs and unleashing gifts
facts fungi have been around for 1.3
billion years
surviving all five great extinction
events
most successful kingdom on the planet
more fungal species than plants and
animals combined
the largest organism on our planet is a
fungal network
honey fungus measuring 2.4 miles across
in the blue mountains in oregon
trees cannot survive without underground
fungal allies 95
of plants use them again
95 of plants
use mycorrhizal networks
fungus root networks two-way resource
exchange
underground harmony we will
biomimic that with our human
architectures
fungi are capable of helping save the
bees
bi-directional communication across long
distances
even across species lines
distributed network archetypes are found
throughout nature
mycelium dark matter neurons the
internet
clearly the strategy works otherwise
nature wouldn't insist on replicating it
the advent of decentralized digital
money seems less
novel and more inevitable
the decentralized network archetype
dna is lindy
fungi in humans both fungi and animals
inhale oxygen exhale carbon dioxide
plants produce their own food through
photosynthesis they're autotrophic
animals and fungi must find their own
food heterotrophic
fungi produce enzymes to externally
digest their environment animals evolve
to have
internal stomach slash brains whereas
fungi pursued external stomach slash
brains
the apisticunt for broad group of
eukaryotes
including animals and fungi
humans share 50 of our dna
with fungi
fungi produce mushrooms which then
release spores
seeds that attempt to colonize life in a
nearby location
mushrooms are simply the reproductive
organ
mushrooms are to the mycelium what
apples
are to a tree
fungi effectively domesticated
photosynthesis machines
algae to harness a self-sustaining food
source
we can think of these algae as little
solar panels
bolted onto fungal networks which made
colonizing
virgin dry land possible
medicinal fungi antibiotics
anti-cancer drugs cholesterol
and ergosterol synthesis inhibitors
psychotropic drugs immunosuppressants
and fungicides
fungi products have been long used in
traditional medicine the ability to
identify beneficial properties and then
extract the active ingredient
started with the discovery of penicillin
by alexander fleming in 1928
which was a factor in the tripling of
our population
since then many potential antibiotics
were discovered
and the potential for various fungi to
synthesize biologically active molecules
useful in various clinical therapies has
been under research
pharmacological research identified
anti-fungal antiviral and anti-protozoan
compounds from fungi
biomimicry networks form
a decentralized consensus on how to use
resources
when to reproduce and what strategy best
defends the organism
nodes determine what software they wish
to run
and enforce the consensus rules they
support accordingly
miners determine which transactions to
include in blocks
exchanges wallets and merchants each
steward large
groups of users each participant in
bitcoin
voluntarily chooses how they wish to
participate
and the aggregate consensus represents
the network
from the left the human heart lightning
the human brain
mycelium roots from a tree an aerial
view of the grand canyon
branches from a tree and the cosmic web
of the universe
ory brothman flat organizations and edge
knowledge during the information economy
decentralized or flat organizations are
more effective with radical inclusion
they resist corruption minimize
bureaucracy and push decision making to
the extremities
where individuals nodes have the most
up-to-date information about the problem
at hand
life without a centralized point of
failure
slime mold designing the tokyo subway
system
ancient fungus slime mold incentivized
to recreate tokyo subway system
each subway stop node was marked with
slime mold's favorite food
oat flakes after 26 hours the slime mold
grew to connect all the no
stops in a more efficient design than
the centrally planned committee of
engineers hired by the japanese
government
slime mold can design a better network
in a day
wow
it's beautiful how it fractals out up
here
in c it goes out with all of its little
sensors
to find the most
oh flakes
and then it
creates a super highway after it finds
that most efficient path
bitcoin versus altcoins some people
think altcoins will implement cool new
features that will eventually out
compete
bitcoin the opposing camp believes
bitcoin will eventually absorb
all the best features after they've been
tested in the market
which makes alternative currencies
unable to compete over the long term
the market sends signals for bitcoin to
create features that satisfy unmet
demands
or improve security as new threats
emerge
vertical and horizontal gene transfer
the separating barrier between these two
is fading
we've been doing vertical as humans for
millions of years via reproduction but
we are doing horizontal meme transfers
which impact our epigenetics for
millennia
especially in the ith we think
the same way fungi actually do
horizontal gene transfers
will be how bitcoin slurps up ideas
produced by altcoins
fungi recycle all matter into base
elements
and act as our planet's immune system
decomposing organic matter transform
rocks branches leaf litter dead animals
and oil spills into their base elements
carbon nitrogen oxygen etc
fungi trade these valuable elements with
nearby organisms
our forests would be buried in hundreds
of feet of leaves and branches if fungi
didn't decompose them
and redistribute the nutrients
fungi eating rocks is the main reason we
have topsoil which enables us to grow
food
it took fungi over 1 billion years to
breed
to produce just the 18 inches of topsoil
that we have today
fungi unlock stranded resources
a tree cannot reuse its own leaves or
branches as the carbon nitrogen
phosphorus are locked in an unusable
form
fungi exploit arbitrage opportunities in
their ecosystem
fungi broker resources underground via
mycelium
between species to ensure the health of
the entire ecosystem
venezuela turkey argentina etc hyper
inflating their currencies
bitcoin steps in as a non-sovereign sov
sov share a voice measure of the market
your brand owns compared to your
competitors
gauges brand visibility in your industry
blockstream launches satellites
able to broadcast bitcoin transactions
to mitigate catastrophic events
bitcoin social contract bitcoin protocol
automates the contract that is agreed
upon on the social layer
the social layer determines the rules of
bitcoin based on the consensus of its
users
fungal reproduction mushrooms are sexual
organs of fungi
felix spores seed delivery systems
some fungi can produce mushrooms with
enough force to break through asphalt
ejaculates basically releasing millions
of spores
then decomposing back into the ground
small percentage of the spores will
travel nearby and form new fungal
colonies
new colonies might stay underground for
several years
before the reproductive cycle continues
again
spores are lighter than air which makes
travel easy
theoretically spores could catch an
updraft and leave earth's orbit
there on a short list of biological
matter capable
of surviving the cold vacuum and
radiation of space panspermia
bitcoin is similar with the reproductive
booms where media floods in and normies
become interested
mushrooms die hype cycles while mycelium
bitcoin thrives underground
cave painting of our oldest
representations of hallucinogen
mushrooms in the world
discovered in northern algeria estimated
to be over 6 000 years old depicted bee
headed mushroom shaman mushrooms in his
hands and growing out of his body
bitcoin 21 million bitcoin cap
100 million satoshi for each bitcoin 2.1
quadrillion tradable units
satoshi nakamoto's white paper as the
bible
there are early forum post
interpretations hermeneutics
roger ver bitcoin jesus in early days
spreading the good word about gifting
spreading the good word by gifting
satoshi's
bitcoin's birth introduced two new
traits openly programmable and
decentralized
rules of bitcoin one no confiscations
two no censorship three no inflation for
anyone can verify rules one through
three
there's their traits of money
you can see fiat is very low in
durability scarcity established history
censorship
resistant unforgeable costliness openly
programmable and decentralized
gold is low in portability divisibility
and openly programmability and bitcoin
is only low in established history
that's it
it's high in everything else
miners rewards for successfully
completing a block have
every to 210 000 blocks or on
average of every four years
so when bitcoin was first published
people were earning
50 bitcoin per block and then it dropped
to 25 about four years later and
four more years later dropped again to
12.5
currently it's at 6.25 bitcoin
per block and a block
is every 10 minutes
somewhere around 2140
the last bitcoin will enter circulation
bitcoin inflation verse time as you can
see here
a very very solidly
strong amount of
monetary base
is now
in circulation enough to where
the inflation rate has
basically decreased
almost all the way down to zero
so the monetary bases at about 80
percent or so and because of that
the inflation is basically near zero
and you can see how it started and where
it's going
are the revolutionaries available supply
decreases as more huddle
which means to hold so people hold
their crypto float is the supply
actively being traded is increasingly
constrained
private keys are lost or people die
without leaving private key instructions
to anybody
each new user puts more upward pressure
on the price
coin shares reports that 77 of bitcoin's
energy consumption is from renewable
resources
renewable sources so
you can see there's the genesis hotel
and there's another hotel 2011 and then
another one in 2014.
there are your jumps in price
collective consciousness of our planet
is changing convincing people that money
isn't green paper or centralized bits
plus
it doesn't need to come from our
government money is the ultimate network
effect its value is determined by the
number of people you can interact with
in a fairly religious sense there are
financial incentives to recruit new
members into the congregation
with each new user that buys bitcoin the
value of bitcoin directionally
increases benefiting previous hodlers
then that new user is incentivized to
convert
their friends who then convert their
friends
as price increases so do the incentives
to improve security as evidenced by the
difficulty adjustment
one of satoshi's most brilliant
contributions
price increases mining becomes more
profitable more miners contribute hash
power
better security makes bitcoin more
valuable
bitcoin is the antivirus mushroom
medicine
the bitcoin fungus is quietly spreading
underground
with each passing day bitcoin is eating
more fiat becoming more robust
more decentralized and more lindy
globally we are facing unprecedented
debt to gdp
levels we'll look back at this archaic
fiat banking experiment with a face palm
for cryptocurrencies the great filter is
surviving nation state level attacks
he who has the gold makes the rules
the cantillian effect the uneven
expansion of the money supply
central banks print new money then the
closest to the monetary injection point
big banks and big corporations
profit from new cheap money spending
extra dollars before prices have
increased
by the time the rest of the population
received the new money price inflation
has already begun
masses receive their new dollars after
prices have increased neutrality of
money
a change in the stock of money affects
only nominal variables in the economy
such as prices wages and exchange rates
with no effect on real variables like
employment real gdp and real consumption
the central bank does not affect the
real economy by creating money
number of jobs size of real gdp amount
of real investment
any increase in the supply of money
would be offset by a proportional rise
in prices and wages
there's the great filters
the amount that we've made it through
and then the very difficult filter
and how important it is for us to get
through so crucial
i care not what puppet has placed upon
the throne of england to rule the empire
on which the sun never sets
the man who controls britain's money
supply controls the british empire and i
control the british money supply nathan
mayor rothschild
give me control of the nation's money
and i care not who makes the laws mayor
amschel rothschild
it's very attractive to the libertarian
viewpoint if we can explain it properly
i'm better with code than with words
though satoshi nakamoto
and me alan i'm better with words and
art than i am with code satoshi i got
you
i will distill all your profundity into
eli 5 and awaken our world
we start with mycorrhizal networks and
inclusive stakeholding
it's not survival of the strongest or
most intelligent survival of the fittest
means most adaptable to change
so it is not the strongest of the money
that survives nor the most intelligent
that survives
it is the one that is most adaptable to
change
just as novel organisms emerge via
speciation to occupy newly created
niches on dry land
bitcoin evolves its dna code to produce
new phenotypes
novel features to take advantage of new
new new niches
bitcoin enables novel financial use
cases that were not possible before
this increases the size of the economic
pie thus generating wealth for society
novelty provided by bitcoin the first
and only implementation of absolute
scarcity
a global near instant a political
settlement system
neutral money not easily captured by
special interests
uncensorable medium of exchange for
black slash gray markets
democratization of basic financial
services
non-sovereign store of value with
negligible barrier to entry
increased inclusive stakeholding
mycorrhizal biomimicry
leads to increased neurodiversity gift
actualization
we will globally reap the emergent
creative fruits in much needed design
art engineering entrepreneurial
scientific and spiritual innovations
tackling our biggest challenges like the
sdgs
without access to a common economic
language bitcoin
many people are unable to participate in
global trade
as bitcoin becomes ubiquitous it
unleashes human productivity
freelancers in venezuela have been have
used bitcoin as a bridge
currency to access usd which effectively
evaded financial controls
a grander vision of the future where
everyone speaks the same economic
language
a global market for talent leads to more
goods and services produced for a
cheaper price
increased trade with developing
countries will help lift people out of
poverty
instead of letting companies fail we
bail them out
the broken incentives create a moral
hazard making the entire system more
fragile
disproportionately hurting the working
class heads i win tails you lose
no one bails out the antelope when it's
eaten by the lion
bitcoin increases economic skin in the
game
which improves the feedback loop leading
to economic evolution by natural
selection
economic darwinism for the win
bitcoin simply needs to outlast its
competition
the ten wreck the common ancestor to all
living placental mammals
an underground survivor for from 65
million plus years ago asteroid
collision
yeast the especially relevant fungal
organism brewers yeast catalyzed human
evolution
fermented drinks like beer and wine
provided a safe way to stay hydrated
as water often contain pathogens that
killed ancient man
the first crops we cultivated were also
the best grains for brewing beer
twelve thousand plus years ago did we
settle down for food stability or to
brew more beer
without fungi say goodbye to all beer
wine chocolate bread and many medicines
such as penicillin
the real problem with humanity is the
following we have paleolithic emotions
medieval institutions and god-like
technology
e.o wilson
money is the most important coordination
mechanism for society
and fiat is running us off a cliff
instead of arguing red versus blue
it's time we address the root cause of
our societal malaise
it's time to unfuck the money fiat is
the exception
not the rule throughout most of history
humans coordinated around a free market
for money
mainly gold and silver bitcoin is an
extended phenotype for humanity
it lowers the trust required for a
global society to communicate
value which enables more sophisticated
cooperation
re-architect society based on the
separation of money and state
aka natural money a huge win for civ
it's our duty to form a symbiosis with
this force
bitcoin was the best performing asset of
the last decade
it's a deflationary asset bitcoin
teaches us to delay consumption today in
order to reap greater benefits tomorrow
rather than charge the fiat system from
the inside
rather than change the fiat system from
the inside we can put our energy towards
a parallel system
bitcoin is the largest implementation of
public key cryptography the world has
ever seen
a world with strong cryptography shifts
the balance of power towards defense
defense from tyranny censorship
overarching governments and surveillance
capitalism
cryptography allows us to assert our
natural rights
bitcoin protects free speech ensuring we
can vote with our money
free speech is the foundation of open
societies
forming symbiosis with bitcoin preserves
freedoms for our future generations
bitcoin metabolizes fiat infrastructures
mycorrhizal biomimicry metabolizes
self-dealing
we can use fungi to clean up oil spills
halt erosion create natural pesticides
and even decompose nuclear waste at
chernobyl
in a similar manner bitcoin can be used
to clean up our dilapidated
fiat infrastructure my co-remediation
equals applied mycology improve our
environments
our processes the legacy system was
designed to siphon wealth from the
bottom to the top most notably during
each financial crisis
and that's best explained through the
asymmetry
that nasim tuleb
teaches where
the bankers get all of the reward
but they take none of the risk because
they can socialize
the losses to the taxpayers
since time is money this forced wealth
transfer system
should be considered systemic time theft
we were promised flying cars and all we
got was 140 characters peter thiel
what about colonizing mars or reducing
the risk of civilization enders such as
pandemics or nuclear war
how about dyson spheres asteroid mining
or eliminating infectious disease and
infant mortality for good
bitcoin accepts short-term price
volatility
in exchange for long-term systemic
stability
fiat offers short-term price stability
at the expense of long-term systemic
risk
we don't account for the fat tail risks
such as banks blowing up or global
pandemics
bitcoin enables an anti-fragile money
system
bitcoin enables an anti-fragile monetary
system
verifying bitcoin transactions
mining hash rate equals miners cpu
spits out hashes 64-digit numbers at
different rates
until they arrive at a solution mega
hashes per second
giga hashes per second or tara hashes
per second hashing equals computing
those countries who produce their own
energy
and mine bitcoin will have further
geopolitical advantage over countries
reliant on
importing energy bitcoin is fully
auditable
hard capped and offers financial
settlement quickly
the perfect neutral money for untrusting
nation states to settle debts
under this light bitcoin is money for
enemies
just like fungi colonizing dry land was
the catalyst for biological evolution
on terra bitcoin is a catalyst for human
evolution
titration the world wide web
microrazal biomimicry the video game
conscious experience biomimicry the
bitcoin
mycorrhizal biomimicry
vr conscious experience biomimicry
the mycelial archetype is embedded in
our species
the mycelial archetype is an emergent
property of biology which means the
world wide web and bitcoin were
inevitable
the reserve currency does not last
forever
there's portugal spain the netherlands
france the britain
and then the us and it's going to be
overthrown
by bitcoin and decentralization
technologies
biomimicking mycorrhizal networks
and over the passage of time
as you see
where we are right now is still only the
early stages
it's about to transition to become a
truly reliable store of value
and then before you know it it will be a
widespread medium of exchange and it'll
be
a convenient unit of account and then
it's going to be
full global money everything will be
satoshi's
everything will be satoshi's
frictionless
borderless hyper efficient
hyper safe
decentralized so get on board early
see these patterns ultimately this is a
pattern
it's making an analogy between
mycorrhizal networks and
decentralization technologies of
cryptocurrencies
especially bitcoin see that
profound analogy if you can see that
profound analogy
you will do very very well these next
couple of decades
but you have to see that profound
analogy
we will do our best to continue
disseminating
information like this that
really attempts to compact
especially in animation the profundity
of this style of knowledge so that it
can land in your heart and you can take
action on it
remember bitcoin metabolizes fiat
infrastructure
mycorrhizal biomimicry metabolizes
self-dealing
re-architect society based on the
separation of money and state
we have to unfuck the money
again the first and only implementation
of absolute scarcity
a global near instant apolitical
settlement system
neutral money not easily captured by
special interests
uncensorable medium of exchange
democratization of basic financial
services
and non-sovereign store value with
negligible barrier to entry
this inclusive stakeholding mycorrhizal
biomimicry will lead to increased
neurodiversity gift actualization across
all of those critical fields that we
desperately need people to
achieve their goals in
remember
where fiat is extremely fragile and
where bitcoin is not
and consider the idea that bitcoin will
absorb all the best features of the alt
coins
after they've been tested in the market
this is one of the
most profound things that i've ever seen
in my life here
slime mold figuring out how to design
the
japanese subway system more effectively
than engineers
patterns patterns patterns patterns
patterns everywhere
find the patterns embody the patterns
become
pattern god and that's how you see the
mycorrhizal networks and the bitcoin
pattern
and analogize them you'll win
if you can do this
our multi-thousand-year relationship
evolutionary
with fungi
decentralize finance defy get pumped
get pumped
the mycelial archetype is embedded
in our species it's an emergent property
of biology which means the world wide
web and bitcoin were
inevitable again
we are biomimicking our civilization
architectures after mycorrhizal networks
that's what bitcoin and decentralization
are get on board early
get on board now let's do this
get pumped read the internet of money by
andreas antonopoulos
read the book of satoshi by phil
champagne these books will onboard you
onto the industry go and watch a bunch
of videos
go and learn go and buy some crypto some
bitcoin you can easily go do that on
coinbase
go and get involved and tell your
friends about it tell your friends that
you've
that you're starting to transition more
and more away from fiat currency
and let's do this guys teach them about
michael reizel networks
go and watch suzanne simmers ted talk
on the mycorrhizal networks
it's very very enriching as well
that's all wanted to keep this second
distillation stream of my notes
shorter than that first one on the
california water supply
go and watch that one if you haven't yet
it's profoundly fascinating
this one again is on fungi bitcoin and
decentralization
i love you very much thank you for
tuning in let me know your thoughts in
the comments below
subscribe if you haven't like the video
share it with other people
and get involved in this
decentralization renaissance
get involved let's do this
much love talk to you soon peace
build the future manifest your dreams
into the world